NATIONAL GUARD TO THE ORDER AND
DOING WHAT THEY WON'T BUT HE
REFUSES.
THE PENTAGON SPOKESMAN JUST SAID
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN CITIZENS
REMAIN TRAPPED IN AFGHANISTAN
TONIGHT, JUST DIDN'T KNOW THE
EXACT NUMBER, JUST THOUSANDS.
MANY OF THEM CAN'T APPARENTLY
GET TO THE BORDER BECAUSE OF THE
TALIBAN-CONTROLLED ROADS.
ISIS IS ALSO OPERATING NEAR THE
AIRPORT BUT TODAY, JOE BIDEN
DENIED THAT ANY AMERICAN
CITIZENS ARE STRANDED.
>> I THINK IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE TO
SAY AMERICANS ARE STRANDED, THEY
ARE NOT.
COMMITTED TO BRINGING AMERICANS
HOME.
WE ARE IN TOUCH WITH THEM VIA
PHONE, TEXT, EMAIL, ANYWAY WE
CAN POSSIBLY REACH AMERICANS TO
GET THEM HOME IF THEY WANT TO
RETURN HOME.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE'S OFFICIAL
POSITION ON WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> I'M JUST CALLING YOU OUT
FIRST THING WE ARE STRANDING
AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> Tucker: YOU'VE REACHED PEAK
LUNACY WHEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CALLS OTHER
PEOPLE IRRESPONSIBLE.
OKAY.
SO WHAT SHOULD WE KNOW ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING THERE
RIGHT NOW?
LOWER LOGAN IS ONE OF THE FEW
WHO DOES KNOW AND HOST LAURA
LOGAN HAS NO AGENDA MUSHY LIVED
IN AFGHANISTAN AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
WHAT CAN WE TRUST ABOUT WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING TONIGHT IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> AS YOU KNOW, I TRY TO FOCUS
ON WHAT ARE THE DEFINING THINGS
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION AND PROPAGANDA
BEING PUSHED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE TALIBAN
AND SO WANT BUT WHAT IS AT THE
HEART AND THE CORE?
FOR EXAMPLE, THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT I THINK AMERICANS
SHOULD UNDERSTAND IS THAT BOTH
THIS COUNTRY'S ENEMIES AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANT YOU TO
ACCEPT THAT THERE IS NOTHING
THAT CAN BE DONE, THAT THIS
OUTCOME THAT YOU SEE WHERE THE
UNITED STATES A WORLD SUPERPOWER
IS HUMILIATED, DEFEATED, AND
SHAMED ON THE WORLD STAGE THAT
IT BOWS AT THE KNEE OF
TERRORISTS, THAT WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THE TALIBAN AS A
LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENT OF
AFGHANISTAN, THAT THEY HAVEN'T
FOUGHT AN ART FIGHTING RIGHT
NOW, THAT THERE IS NO
RESISTANCE.
THIS FOREGONE CONCLUSION WAS
WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO ACCEPT
BECAUSE AS LONG AS WE ARE
TALKING AND ARGUING ABOUT HOW
MANY AMERICAN CITIZENS ARE LEFT
BEHIND AND SO ON, WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT ALL
OF THESE DECISIONS THAT BROUGHT
US HERE ARE POLITICAL.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
YES, THERE WERE MANY FAILURES
ALONG THE WAY BUT THE FRAMEWORK
WITHIN THE GENERAL OPERATING IS
THE POLITICAL FRAMEWORK.
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF AS A
POLITICIAN, NOT A MILITARY MAN
AND THEY LOVE TO REMIND US ALL
OF THAT, SO THE POLITICAL
DECISION THAT RESULTED IN THIS
OUTCOME HAS NOT CHANGED ONE BIT.
THERE IS NOTHING.
THEY ARE NOT USING ANY OF THE
LEVERS OF POWER IN ANY
DIMENSION, NOT POLITICAL,
DIPLOMATIC, ECONOMIC, NOT
SECURITY WISE, NOT MILITARY.
SO YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT AND
SAY OKAY, THEY ARE GETTING THE
OUTCOMES THEY WANT BECAUSE THEY
CAN BOMB THE TALIBAN INTO THE
STONE AGE LIKE THAT.
THEY CAN DESTROY ALL THOSE
WEAPONS THAT ARE IN PLACE, THEY
CAN TELL PAKISTAN TO CEASE AND
DESIST RIGHT NOW OR WE ARE
TURNING OFF THE MONEY.
THEY CAN TELL THEM STOP DOING
THESE BIG EVACUATIONS OF AFGHAN
WOMEN, AND THE MOUNTAINEERING
TEAM.
WHEN YOU ARE FUNDING THE TALIBAN
AND YOU FIND THIS INVASION.
HE WAS THE LEVERS OF YOUR POWER
AND THEN ADVANCED MILITARY
TECHNOLOGY THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY HAS.
THE KIND OF THING, WE HAVE
THERMAL DRONES I CAN SEE THROUGH
WALLS.
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN, NONE OF THIS
CAPABILITY HAS BEEN USED, SO
THAT'S A BROADER QUESTION AS TO
WHY NOT.
THE REAL QUESTION HERE IS WHY
ARE WE EXPECTING THAT ALL OF
THESE WOMEN IN AFGHANISTAN ARE
CONDEMNED TO A DEATH SENTENCE,
RIGHT?
AND THAT ALL THEIR DREAMS ARE
OBLITERATED WHEN WE COULD
ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
THE CHINESE ARE CROWING TODAY,
ALL OVER THE STATE NEWS AGENCY
AND THEY ARE MOCKING JOE BIDEN
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND SO WE ARE ACCEPTING THIS
DEFEAT THAT PUTS THIS COUNTRY IN
JEOPARDY AND THE SECOND THING
THAT I THINK IS A DEFINING, REAL
QUESTION HERE IS WE ARE ALSO
ACCEPTING THE IDEA THAT IF YOU
CRITICIZE THIS, YOU ARE AFFECT
ADVOCATING TO STAY IN
AFGHANISTAN AND THAT IS FALSE.
THERE ARE MANY OTHER OPTIONS
WITHOUT STAYING IN AFGHANISTAN
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, THIS IS
NOT JUST ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
THIS DOESN'T JUST EMPOWER
AL QAEDA AS THE A TERRORIST, IT
EMPOWERS EVERY ENEMY THE
UNITED STATES HAS.
HE DOESN'T JUST DISCOURAGE THE
ALLIES WE HAVE IN AFGHANISTAN,
IT TELLS EVERY NATION ON EARTH
WE ARE A TERRIBLE ALLY.
FRIENDS LIKE THIS, YOU DON'T
NEED ENEMIES.
YOU CAN'T DO THIS ALONE.
FOR OUR SECURITY GLOBALLY, WE
NEED FRIENDS.
WHEN WE NEEDED HELP, WE WENT TO
THE AFGHANS AND SAID PLEASE HELP
US AND I'LL TELL YOU WHAT AN
AFGHAN LEADER SAID TO ME TODAY,
EVERY MEETING BEGAN WITH WE
WON'T BETRAY YOU AGAIN OR
ABANDON YOU AGAIN, WE MADE A
MISTAKE AND WE PROMISE YOU THIS
TIME WE WON'T DO IT AND THEN THE
IRANIANS WERE TELLING US AND
SAYING AMERICA WILL ABANDON YOU
AGAIN.
WE ARE YOUR NEIGHBOR, WE WILL BE
HERE WHEN THEY DO AND WHAT YOU
ARE SEEING HAS A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION PROVING THAT
EVERY ENEMY OF AMERICA AND
EVERYTHING THEY'VE EVER SAID
ABOUT THIS COUNTRY IS THE TRUTH.
>> Tucker: THERE IS GOING TO
BE A MAJOR REALIGNMENT AND I
AGREE WITH YOUR POINT.
JUST BECAUSE YOU CRITICIZE IT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU WERE ARGUING
FOR ANOTHER 20 YEARS OF
OCCUPATION.
THERE WERE NO OTHER OPTIONS.
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON.
INTERESTING CONVERSATIONS EVER
ON THE SUBJECT ON A BRAND-NEW